[Music]
mirror mirror
on the wall
most of the time i'm wasting my bullets
on my own people i'm sure that they're
nothing
i love shooting at bad guys
the guy killed me in the air literally i
was in the air i died
guys if you're watching this you like
playing games don't forget to praise
allah yeah okay
very important what if they do forget
though
that's pete can you imagine you're
losing your hair after because you're
too please you're too busy playing this
game
can you imagine you you can imagine this
gender because you're too busy playing
call of duty
i would have been lucky i'm giving a
reminder people are shooting at me
there's hate
how would you see that wait that's not
for love what's going on oh
that i think that was both of us we died
together
i'm trying to give a reminder people are
killing me bro
yeah guys imagine you're playing this
game it's not even bloody real
yes it's entertaining but it gets a
little bit dangerous when you get really
hooked on it and you're missing summer
and you're justifying missing summer
if i was you guys i'll start getting
concerned yeah there's nothing wrong
with having entertainment and playing et
cetera
but it's very very important to dedicate
time it's a lot what five minutes
and you know what's really important is
that when you're playing these games
sometimes what happens is
you you get shot in from behind command
i'm trying it you have to throw grenades
again that's
what happens is when you're so into the
game even when you're praying salah
you've got no kosher
you're just literally uh let me quickly
uh
it becomes like a uh what's the word
uh call of duty no man
it becomes like a to-do task in the area
um i don't know i just died
can you at least do some janaz or
something bro
i am don't worry where'd you die